القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها تصدت لهجوم
صاروخي روسيا استهدف العاصمه كييف خلال
زياره القاده الافارقه
واضافت ان القوات الروسيه اعتقد سته
صواريخ كينجال وسته صواريخ كاليبر
ومسيرتين في وقت واحد واعلنت السلطات في
تضرر منزل ضمن حدود مقاطعه كيف جراء القصف
ادوا يزور وفد وساطه افريقيه يقوده
الرئيسان السنغالي
والجنوب افريقيا سيرين لا راما فورزا
العاصمه الاوكرانيه قبل توجهه الى روسيا
ويحمل الوفد مقترحا لحل الازمه يتضمن عده
نقاط ويدعو بحسب بقاله رويترز لانسحاب
القوات الروسيه وازاله الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه من بيلاروسيا وتعليق مذكره
التوقيف الصادره عن المحكمه الجنائيه بحق
الرئيس الروسي بما يسمح بتوفير بيئه
مواتيه لوقف اطلاق النار
هذا وقال الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير
زيلينسكي انه لن يكون هناك اي تفاوض مع
روسيا مع استمرار احتلالها لاراضي
اوكرانيه واضاف خلال مؤتمرا صحفيا مع وفد
القاده الافارقه الذي يزورك انا بلاده
تدعو الى سلام حقيقي وانسحاب روسيا من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لن يكون هناك اي تفاوض مع روسيا وهي تستمر
في احتلال الاراضي الاوكرانيه لان ذلك
يعني استمرار الاحتلال وهدم تحاول روسيا
القيام به منذ سنوات وهي تحاول العوده الى
خدعها القديمه وخداع الجميع لكن روسيا لن
تستطيع خداع اي طرف خصوصا اوكرانيا ندعو
الى سلام حقيقي والى انسحاب الروسيين
حقيقي من اراضي اوكرانيا المستقله
زياره الوفد الافريقي لروسيا قال ان رئيس
فلاديمير بوتين منفتح دائما على ايه
احتمال لمعالجه المساله الاوكرانيه اوضح
ان الازمه الاوكرانيه يمكن معالجتها بطرق
مختلفه وان بوتين يدعم اي افكار لانهاء
النزاع
كيف مراسل الجزيره عدنان البوريني عدنان
الى اي مدى هناك ربما تطابق او تناقض بين
ما يطالب به الوفد الافريقي وما قالهنسكي
هذا اليوم
لا يوجد توضيح كبير
للاعلان الاوكراني الذي جاء على لسان
الرئيس بلدي وايضا كان يلمح اليه من قبل
مسؤولين اخرين هنا مثل مدير مكتب مدير
مكتب الرئاسه وايضا وزير الخارجيه يوحي
بانه عدم التطابق كبير تتحدث اوكرانيا عن
ان ايه مفاوضات او محادثات ينبغي ان تبدا
مع روسيا ينبغي ان تكون بعد انسحاب القوات
الروسيه من اراضي الاوكرانيه اما يقوله
الرئيسكي في تصريحاته يقول ان اوكرانيا
تسعى لعدم تطبيع الوضع مع مع حاله الحرب
في حال بدات المحادثات اثناء وجود القوات
الروسيه داخل اراضيها وبالتالي تشدد ثياب
على ان خطه الرئيس فلاديميرزلينز كما يسمى
هنا بخطه النقاط العشره هي الاساس الذي
ينبغي ان تنطلق منه اي محادثات واي
مفاوضات تقول كيف بشكل او باخر بان هذا
الانسحاب شرط اساسي الرد اليوم كان بشكل
او باخر لم عن السقف الردود الاخرى على
المبادرات السابقه نتحدث حتى عن المبادره
الصينيه التي تقدمت كثيرا لكنها نالت بعض
التشكيك نتيجه
تشكيك غربي بموقف الصين وصفافاتها
المبادره الاندونيسيه التي اعتبرتها
مع الطرح الروسي المبادره البرازيليه التي
ايضا لم تلقى صدى الرد الاوكراني يشدد
دوما على ان الحديث عن بدء المحادثات
والمفاوضات باي شكل من الاشكال قبل انسحاب
القوات الروسيه هو مرفوض وهذا ما تحدث به
الرئيس فلاديميرزلين اليوم ايضا تم الحديث
عن ان الاشارات التي ارسلت اثناء وجود
الوفد الافريقي الحديث عن استقبال كياب
نحو 12 صاروخا بالستيا ومسييرتين في وقت
واحد قالت القوات الجويه بطبيعه الحال
انها تصدت لها اعتبرتها كييف بانها دليل
على ان الموقف الروسي تجاه عمليه التسويه
او المحادثات موقف ليس جديا بشكل او باخر
وبالتالي هذا ما ابلغه الرئيس
الافريقي بحسب ما جاء في المؤتمر الصحفي
على ايه حال هذا المشهد الدبلوماسي بشكل
او باخر لا يوقف عمل القوات الاوكرانيه في
الجبهات جمال نتحدث عن جبهات يستمر فيها
القتال ضمن ما يسمى بالهجوم المضاد تحديدا
في منطقه الشرق تقول القوات الاوكرانيه
بانها تتقدم وتواصل التقدم في تلك المنطقه
على الاقل وان كان لبضع مئات امتار نتحدث
عن بخ موت نتحدث عن مدن اخرى في تلك
الجبهه اليوم كان هناك قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه في جبهه باخموت وتحدث عن هذا
الامر بشكل
عدنان البوريني وراسل الجزيره متحدثا
الينا من العاصمه الاوكرانيه شكرا لك